hello everyone and welcome to another
video uh that we will be showing another
brilliant victory uh
by by none other than alireza who who
played a spectacular tournament and won
both the rapid and the blitz section
okay in the rapid he was tied with
maxine but um
the points are uh
added together at the end of the five
days of rapid and blitz and alireza just
uh pretty much obliterated everyone he
did lose that one game in rapid at the
fabiana caruana but other than that he
was uh
truly a spectacular performance and um
this is the the last game we'll be
showing from the event and uh
by latest if you guys have any other
that you would like to see do use
hashtag suggestion and i will go over
them uh but uh yeah all in all just uh
truly an incredible performance and uh
he he
like you probably you guys probably have
seen this but uh um alireza started this
event as a 2700 player 27 something and
he finished it as a 2900 player so he
completely skipped the 2800
he won over 100 rating points in this
event which is uh which is pretty pretty
crazy uh and you don't see it very often
but um yeah we're going to get to that
and we're going to discuss the standings
a little bit but now let's check out the
game it's again from the final round
there is a versus linear dominguez perez
uh really a wild one and again alireza
opens with none other than the english
we have pawn to c4 and before we
actually check out the game i forgot to
mention yesterday yesterday i was
playing a game unleashes uh i usually
play a few bullet games for a few blitz
games before i start recording sort of
to get in the mood to
you know talk about chess and uh i lost
to a gentleman named um seamon 56 and uh
he sent me a message he said uh give me
a shout out in the video uh next time
you make a video and i said okay if you
if you win one more game then i will do
it and then he beat me again i played
the evan's gambit i played uh oh no it
wasn't evan's game but it was sort of a
sillion but i played b4 and i tried to
play like an evan's game but it was a
fun game and i i had a nice position but
in the end he just defended well and i i
couldn't pull it off so a shout out to
simon 56 uh that's seaman with a y if
you guys want to challenge him and you
know try and avenge me uh that is up to
you but yeah a good game sir now getting
back to this game so alireza opens with
c4 we have c5 uh we have g3 g6 going for
the symmetrical variation bishop g2
bishop to g7 and now knight to c3 with
knight to c6 and now pawn to d3 phone to
d6 and now there are a couple of very
very popular moves here like bishop d2
a3 pawn to e3 uh rook to b1 uh but
alireza goes for queen to c2 this is uh
another extremely rare but it is rare uh
sorry not queen to c to queen to d2 it's
uh fairly rare uh we have e6 by
dominguez and now pawn to b3 of course
the bishop will now be fianchettoed as
the other bishop was as well
uh knight g to e7 and the bishop to b2
now we have castles and knight to f3 uh
interestingly there is a game from last
year's saint louis blitz tournament
where uh dominguez had this exact same
position or linear dominguez as i i
understand that's how you guys uh uh
prefer uh uh for me to call him uh
either or either linear or dominguez
perez uh as uh one is the middle name
one is the last name but okay uh so uh
the point is that he already had this
position against wesley so last year in
this exact same event and wesley
defeated him with h4 and it's incredible
that alireza was able to you know
prepare this as you play so many games
so many blitz games so many rapid games
uh
so uh very very nice preparation and he
uh deviates from that game with knight
to f3 which is a new move because this
is not a rare position there are like
ten games in the database with top
players reaching this position i think
there's one where wesley played h4 i
think levon played h4 i think uh maybe
artemis played h4 uh but here knight to
f3 by alireza and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
and it's going to be a different one
than the one that then the position that
arrives after h4 so d5 uh of course
doming uh dominguez perez strikes in the
center uh we have castles and now pawn
to d for grabbing more space
knights to a4 and now pawn to b6 and
here after e3 uh linear just plays pawn
to e5 because
he doesn't want to trade if he trades he
just allows the knight back into the
game here uh he's basically asking
galeresa how are you going to get your
knight bishop and rook into the game for
the moment they really aren't doing
anything and if you if you capture you
kind of allow exactly that for example
the characters are as i would play f
captures as he does have to keep an eye
on that bishop but like i said if bishop
captures just knight captures and now
you've solved all of his problems so
here uh linear will force all it is that
approved why this is um
in any way playable for white
e captures on d4 we have e captures on
d4 and now pawn to a3 all it is i will
use b4 to weaken the d4 pawn in the
future so a5 stopping b4 and now rook f2
e1
we have rooked a b8 now adding a
defender to the b6 pawn now the queen
can be developed and now bishop the c1
so now you see what algae is doing he
will move the queen he will try to
develop the bishop to f4 and then this
rook is coming to a2 and e2 this is how
he will mobilize his pieces so h6 uh
taking away the g5 square from alireza's
pieces queen to d1 and now pawn to g5 of
course stopping bishop to f4 we have
rook to a2 preparing rook a to e2 and
now bishop to d7 and now uh just h4 bile
it is a
saying that okay you either have to play
f6 which looks really weird or you push
g4 and then you no longer have the f4
square controlled by our pawn and even
though f6 looks really weird it it is
the way to go i'm just going to show it
because it's a really fun line for
example captures captures and now
alireza could uh go for this um a very
nice sacrifice with bishop captures on
g5 anything other than this and then the
linear should be perfectly fine but
after this trade uh he gets two piece
two pawns for a piece and he will get
some sort of an attack going on with
bishop to d5 maybe in the future if the
knight moves so it's a very very tricky
to play this uh and probably what
alireza would have gone for but a linear
win for g4 knights the h2 attacking the
pawn here now with the knight end with
um the queen and here just pawn to h5
and like we said now you've really uh
pushed as far as you can go but you no
longer control the df4 square with your
pawn on g5 so bishop to f4 but before
that pawn to f3 by all it is it's like
he can see the future and uh
you'll see what i mean by this because
bishop to f4 uh does make sense here you
develop peace you attack the rule comes
with tempo
but here we have knight to e5 by linear
uh bishop to e5 was also very nice just
going after that g3 pawn but okay it's
blitz so 95 uh f captus and g for h
captures now rook a to e2 preparing to
capture on e5 so pawn to f6 and now rook
to e4 sort of uh
baiting linear to go for bishop to c6
and attack that rook and he does go for
this bishop to c6 queen to c8 or knight
to f5 are the way to go but bishop to c6
uh falls right into
uh alireza's uh
trap and that is of course the play uh
knight captures on g4 he gives up the
exchange and uh uh well he will get the
attack because the light squares are
weakened around the black king and if
lanier wants to grab material he will
have to give up the light square bishop
but there's really nothing better so
bishop captures uh we have rook captures
on e4 and now knight captures on g4
still with knight to f5 it's still uh
it's still a
strong game uh but here knight captures
on g4 of course queen captures is
impossible due to f5 so rook captures on
g4 and now pawn to f5 we have rook g5
and now uh we have rook to f6 and this
is what i mean uh what i meant uh
uh when i said what i said if you guys
remember uh feel free to pause the video
now and try to find the absolute best
way to continue this game and win it for
alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting and uh
paying attention and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course bishop to f4 look at this it's a
free move with the bishop uh or rather
it's two free moves with the bishop
because we play bishop f4 we attack the
rook here and once this rook moves
because on the previous move a linear
played rook to f6 we get another free
move with the bishop so it's basically
like the bishop teleports from c1 to e5
uh for for free uh so what you're gonna
do rook the c8 we have bishop to e5 now
uh attacking the rook rook the g6 now
and now comes the bishop to d5 with
check queen h5 is playable but the
bishop to d5 is the move you play in
blitz of course uh because the knight is
uh overloaded uh cannot defend the rook
on g6 and grab the bishop on d5 so here
king to f8 and now only now queen to h5
putting even more pressure on this rook
uh and of course now the rule cannot
capture if you capture then queen to f7
is checkmate the bishop on d5 now makes
this possible so bishop captures an e5
was played but now just rook captures
and g6 knight captures queen captures
and now how do you defend checkmate uh
you have to play something queen the c7
was played but now you allow all sorts
of other tricky moves like knight
captures and v6 attacks the rook broke
the d8 and now just queen the g8 with
check king e7 queen f7 check and now as
the rook takes away the d8 square from
the black king uh
the only square available is king to d6
but of course then queen to e6 will be
checkmate so it was in this position on
move 37 that linear dominguez perez
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here once you move the
king it is checkmate and uh well what uh
what a game just truly truly spectacular
uh just bullying everyone with the
english opening
in the symmetrical variation uh it is uh
definitely something you don't see every
day i mean every every game against
everyone just the english english
english and achieving such
spectacular positions such you know
aesthetically pleasing positions what's
what's even more and uh yeah uh this is
the final game of course by this point
has already won the tournament so uh he
didn't have to worry all that much you
know about the placement about the money
but um but
he could just play good chess you know
fun chess and then win some games uh but
uh this is what i wanted to show you
guys at the this is now uh the the top
20 blitz players in the world these are
the live ratings you can see that
nakamura and firuja both are over 2 900.
uh hikaru won 58 points in this event
and alireza won
107.6 points so this is what i meant
when i said that he started as a 2700
player and he completely you know leaped
over 2800 and went straight into 2900
but even with that he's behind hikaru uh
he did overtake hikaru at some point
during the event but hikaru just uh you
know did what he called us best he
played uh you know really fast chess
really well and he of course is now the
top rated player a blitz player in the
world then you have karana in third
artemia of carlson in fifth arena and
giri dubois
arjun in 15th uh really really
incredible stuff andre kim mommy jarvan
and bauer and fedossif uh those are the
current top 20 in the live live
standings and these are the final
standings of the event uh so now let's
check that out as well uh alireza wins
the entire event so this is a combined
score of both uh blitz and and rapid
with 26 out of 36 uh then hikaru
nakamura or i don't know is it uh no
this is i believe only from the
uh only from the blitz uh
yeah this is this is only from the blitz
yeah uh so 26 out of 36 then hikaru with
21 out of 36 fabiano corona with night
or no it's it's combined yeah what am i
saying it's combined uh or i don't know
what i'm saying uh but yeah alireza did
win the tournament with 26 out of 36 uh
which is incredible hikaru uh 21 out of
36 then we uh we have a tie at 19.
fabiano caron and maxima shira legra
with 19 yanipongashi with 18 out of 36
17 and a half but for mamidarov lavon
and jeffrey young with 17 out of 36 sam
shanklin 13 and a half out of 36 in
dominguez perez linear uh 12 out of 36
and now you can see how how impressive
uh alireza's achievement here is if we
for example if you
remove alireza from this
table you can see that uh if if only
these were the players hikaru would have
won a very nice event in some very very
strong competition two points two full
points ahead of the field but now once
you add alireza to the mix you can see
how impressive his performance is uh
next next to all of them so truly truly
incredible performance uh big
congratulations and uh well we'll only
see what the the future brings but uh
for the moment the the future does seem
bright for this uh
for this young gentleman who who just
came you know to st louis and destroyed
everyone with the english opening
uh so yeah that's the game and a little
bit of extra info hope you guys uh
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
gary sharma as i mean parsons suzy shaw
of course
and frederick
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day